holy [ __ ] and someone actually asked me  recently why do I keep doing these  pressors when the Internet is so full of  [ __ ] its fitness for gamers and  there are no gyms no awkward progress  selfies or overly enthusiastic  instructors that make you want to punch  them and then yourself in the face the  fact is that dancing makes people happy  and frankly I can't think of a place  that needs dancing more than a post  pandemic New York City where millions of  people have died from a variant  contagion just bleeding from all your  orifices makes you want to jump up and  shake it it is exciting it is terrifying  it's ab lifting it's even going to get a  little sweaty it's hella [ __ ] smoky  apparently it's 4:20 in this [ __ ]  everybody clapping is in the back of the  theater because they were late